>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
IT'S ONE OF THE MAINSTREAM
DESTROY TRUMP FAVORITE
TACTICS TO PREVENT YOU FROM
GETTING THE WHOLE STORY.
IT'S CALLED BIAS OF
OMISSION.
TODAY IT WAS ON FULL
DISPLAY.
DESPITE THE BOMBSHELL
REVELATIONS IN THE
GRASSLEY-GRAHAM MEMO AND
PRETTY DAMNING TEXT MESSAGES
HERE WITH REACTION SKY
BRIDGE CAPITAL I'M SORRY,
SHOW TONIGHT.
>> THE PRICKS ATTACKING ME,
SEAN.
IT WASN'T LIBERALS.
THAT'S THE CRAZY PART ABOUT
IT.
>> Sean: THAT'S TRUE.
YOU TAKE HEAT FROM ALL
COVERS.
AND THE AUTHOR OF THE SMEAR,
OPERATIVES AND FAKE NEWS
CONTROLS WHAT YOU SEE, WHAT
YOU THINK, AND HOW YOU VOTE.
THE ANCHOR OF FULL MEASURE
ALL RIGHT, ANTHONY, TO ME, I
THIS IS THE BIGGEST
CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN THE
HISTORY, PERHAPS, MODERN DAY
POLITICS.
IT IS -- IT MAKES WATERGATE
LOOK LIKE STEALING A
SNICKER'S BAR.
>> THE PROBLEM YOU ARE
CALLING IT THAT NOW.
WE STILL HAVE ANOTHER 10
LAYERS TO DRILL INTO AND RIP
OFF MORE SKIN.
AND SO ONCE YOU GET REALLY
SO WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO MAKE A
MOVEMENT.
READ THE MANIFESTO THE BEST
SELLING BOOK BY SHARYL
ATTKISSON.
>> Sean: I HAVE.
EVERYBODY.
FLATTEN UP EVERYBODY,
DEHUMANIZE THEM.
TRY TO CRIMINALIZE THE
PROCESS OF FINDING OUT THE
PEOPLE.
I'M GLAD YOU ARE EXPOSING
IT, SEAN, YOU ARE DOING A
BIG SERVICE.
A PATRIOTIC SERVICE AND YOU
ARE PROTECTING THE PRESIDENT
WHO HONESTLY WON THE
ELECTION DESPITE ALL OF THIS
NONSENSE THAT WAS HAPPENING
IN THE POLITICIZATION OF
THESE AGENCIES.
>> Sean: IN MANY WAYS,
THIS WAS ALMOST A YEAR AGO
ON THIS PROGRAM WE BROKE THE
STORY RIGHT HERE WITH SARA
CARTER AND JOHN SOLOMON DONE
INCREDIBLE WORK YEAH THEY
GOT A FISA WARRANT AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
MEDIA WENT CRAZY.
TURNS OUT EVERYTHING AND
MUCH MORE WE HAVE BEEN
LITERALLY UNPEELING LAYERS
OF AN ONION HERE WITH REAL
FACTS AND INFORMATION THE
COLLUSION WITH ZERO EVIDENCE
FOR A YEAR AND BIOMISSION
DON'T COVER THESE STORIES.
WHY?
>> JUST TO AMEND ONE THING.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY HAD A
FISA WARRANT DIRECTLY ON
DONALD TRUMP I HAVEN'T SEEN
EVIDENCE THAT THEY HAD.
>> Sean: WELL, CARTER PAGE.
>> THEY MAY HAVE USED
WARRANTLESS TECHNIQUES.
THERE IS ALL KINDS OF WAYS I
THAT INTEL OFFICIALS AND I
USING BAD INFORMATION TO
BRING TO THE FISA COURT TO
WRAP UP OTHER PEOPLE THAT
ARE THE TRUE TARGETS.
WRAP THEM UP INCIDENTAL
WITHOUT A DIRECT WARRANT.
>> Sean: ISN'T THAT WHAT
ISN'T THAT WHAT HAPPENED TO
POOR GENERAL FLYNN.
>> OF COURSE.
>> I THINK FROM WHAT WE KNOW
FROM NEWS REPORTING AND
SINCE THEN UNDER THE OUTSIDE
AUSPNESSES OF LISTENING
AUSPICSSES OF LISTENING
AUSPICESES OF LISTENING
AUSPICES O OF LISTENING
AUSPICES OFOF LISTENING
AUSPICES OF L LISTENING
AUSPICES OF LISTENING TO
OFFICIAL FROM AMBASSADOR TO
WHO MAY HAVE BEEN ALLEGEDLY
THEIR TRUE TARGET HOPEFULLY
HAVE ONE PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE THAT PAYS FOR A
PHONY RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
NONE OF IT IS VERIFIED AND
SHE IS ALSO, CHRISTOPHER
STEELE IS BEING FED FROM
CLINTON'S OWN ASSOCIATE.
THEN THEY DON'T TELL A FISA
JUDGE THE FACTS OF WHO
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR THIS
PHONY DOSSIER THAT'S
UNVERIFIED.
AND THEN IT'S USED TO GET A
FISA WARRANT.
LEAKING RAW INTELLIGENCE.
AND THE MEDIA, FOR THE MOST
PART.
THERE HAS BEEN A BLACKOUT.
ISN'T THAT TRUE?
>> I THINK THERE HAS LARGELY
BEEN A LACK OF CURIOSITY AND
SIDE OF THIS ISSUE.
THERE HAS BEEN PLENTY
REPRESENTING ONE VIEWPOINT.
VERY LITTLE ON THE OTHER
SIDE EXCEPT TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT DEBUNKS.
BIGGER SCANDAL UNDER THE
THAT THEY WERE GOING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP, PERHAPS,
DURING THE CAMPAIGN BUT WHY
BECAUSE UNLIKE WHAT THEY
THOUGHT WOULD HAPPEN IF JEB
BUSH WERE ELECTED OR HILLARY
CLINTON.
THERE ARE SOME INSIDE THE
THAN ONE ADMINISTRATION WHO
FEARED THAT DONALD TRUMP
COULD BRING IN PEOPLE WHO
COULD PEEL BACK THE LAYERS
AND SEE THE IMPROPER AND
IMPLEMENTED FOR A LONG TIME.
>> Sean: DEEP STATE, ANTHONY
SCARAMUCCI, DEEP STATE CASE.
LONGER ARE WE GOING TO
TOLERATE THIS?
HAPPENING, HOW DO WE DEAL
WITH THESE PEOPLE, SEAN,
BECAUSE SHERYL MYSELF AND
YOU KNOW HOW RUTHLESS AND
DIABOLICAL THEY ARE THEY
WILL DO ANYTHING TO STOP
SCHUMER SAYS THEY WILL GET
YOU SIX WAYS AND SUNDAY AND
THIS GUY ON FAKE NEWS CNN
SAYING WIN.
>> THAT MONSTER SAYING WE
ARE AROUND FOR 100 PLUS
YEARS AND YOU ARE AROUND FOR
13 MONTHS.
THIS IS SORT OF NONSENSE.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THEIR
GOVERNMENT IS THERE TO SERVE
THEM WE ARE NOT HERE TO
SERVE THE PEOPLE THAT WORK
IN THE GOVERNMENT.
THEY ARE ALL SERVANTS AND
THEY NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE THAT
UNSENSE GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: LAST WORD SHARYL
ATTKISSON.
>> MUCH MORE TO COME.
LOOK AT THE BIG PICTURE AND